so if you have trouble being productive
then I would consider entering a season
of no Warren Buffett once said the
difference between successful people and
really successful people is that really
successful people say no to almost
everything when I look at the periods of
my life in business where I've had huge
amounts of growth in very short periods
of time I've gone through things that I
call the season of no and a season of no
isn't forever but it's just for now and
sometimes seasons can be three months
sometimes seasons can be three years the
longest season of know that I had was a
three year season during that season of
no I said no to friends I was a little
bit extreme but I also was running from
absolute poverty and I had started
seeing some success and I was so afraid
of messing it up that I said no to
alcohol so I stopped drinking entirely I
stopped saying yes to any social events
I was in a paid group that I was paying
like 35 000 a year to be in and I didn't
go to any of the events for two years
even though I paid for it a lot of
people think it hurts to say no to
things because it does because you feel
like you're rejecting other people and
most of us have been on the other side
of that that and feeling rejected sucks
you have to kind of trick your brain
into thinking that the no is actually a
yes to the thing that matters most
because the way that I've always thought
about this was from my first principal's
perspective of if I achieve this really
big thing in three years or five years
all of these doors will be open for me
but if I allow these onesie twosy
one-off conversations one-off favors
one-off things to take me away from that
one big thing I know that five years
from now me not having the thing makes
it far less likely that even those first
doors are still open they're only
reaching out to me now because of the
little bit of success that I've
experienced which I got here because of
being focused on the one thing that
mattered most Jim Watson the big 50
million dollar whatever exit was built
during a season of no and all the people
that I said no to
still hit me up but if I hadn't built
that during a season of no and I had
said yes to all these little things and
I said no to the thing that mattered
most they might not be here still
hitting me up there's two scenarios that
I play out in my head one is that at the
end of this where you achieve something
95 of people are going to be even
further behind you and so you'll still
have access to them the people who were
on par with you shoulder to shoulder
always mutual respect you still also
have access to them if for some reason
someone is offended that you said no to
them earlier on guess what there are
other people that in this future state
will walk into your life and so there's
a lot of no's that I made early on that
I can't even remember the door that
probably permanently shut because I have
so many other doors that have opened for
me I like to think of yeses that I give
to other people as withdrawals from my
personal energy account and I think of
knows as deposits into my gold account
here's our Warren Buffett told people to
make goals he said write down your 25
top goals in life he's a said really
think about it make them in order 1 to
25 then Circle the top five tear off
everything underneath and throw it away
because those are the only things that
matter during a season of no I put all
of my effort into the one goal of those
five that matters the most to me then I
write down what is the minimum that I
have to do to not move backwards in
these ones kind of like bodybuilding you
usually can only work on one weakness at
a time Steve Jobs said people think
Focus means saying yes to the thing
you've got to focus on but that's not
what it means at all it means seeing no
to a hundred other good ideas that are
out there you have to pick carefully I'm
actually as proud of the things we
haven't done as the things I have done
when you think about focusing right you
think well focusing is saying yes no
focusing is about saying no Innovation
is saying no to a thousand other good
ideas there's the opportunistic yeses
and no's that we have to make so the
better and better your business gets the
more attractive the opportunities that
will present themselves and so you may
have this marketing agency for example
and it's doing well but then all of a
sudden one of your clients is like hey
man how about I give you equity in my
business and you keep doing the
marketing for me and then you start
thinking yourself well yeah because I'm
gonna make more on this deal I should do
this deal but the thing is is there's so
much inefficiency in this one-off or
ones you choose your relationship that
you lose on the main thing if you build
this massive agency that's the thing
that everyone's going to come to you for
if you have this weird thing with two or
three odd appendages from these one-off
deals I'll tell you as an investor when
I see that I see an undisciplined
entrepreneur I see someone who cannot
focus on the thing that matters most and
that's why when we talk about leverage
in terms of getting more for what you
put in that's why being so selective on
the one thing that matters most is so
important because most people don't
achieve the success they want because
they either don't do the thing that
matters most enough times they don't do
it for long enough or they're doing the
wrong thing altogether most plans taken
to their natural end are actually pretty
good so even if you had a local business
that was a dry cleaning business if you
did it for 40 years never got distracted
I promise you that one you'd have a
pretty good dry cleaning business too
you'd probably have multiple locations
and three you might have been able to
scale Nationwide I was in the gym space
for a decade so I could have gone into
probably having 100 locations of my own
or doing the franchise route I went the
licensing route but just staying in that
game for a decade straight without doing
anything else and when I did do
something else which is why I make these
videos because it was one of my bigger
mistakes I started the supplement
company and I probably shouldn't have
done that I probably should have kept
doing the main thing there's also the no
of doing work that's below your pay
grade this actually happened with the
portfolio company recently they have
access cash flow they're making profit
every month but the CEO in the short
term didn't want their cash flow to go
down there was this clear role that he
was spending 10 to 15 hours a week on it
I'm like dude that's two full days of
your work week but he didn't want to
give it to somebody else because it
wasn't 40 hours of this week do you not
think that in the two full other days
you can make up for the work that you
shouldn't be doing that somebody else
can do and realistically they'll do it
better than you because they're actually
fully focused on it rather than trying
to get it done you have to say no this
is going to be a controversial one to
family obligations we even say the word
family obligation as though it's assumed
and expected it's a choice it's a Family
Choice I'm not saying don't talk to your
family
I'm saying you might not want to talk to
your mom every day what you really have
is a family trade-off you're going to
trade getting a one-off comment or a
stink eye you think you're too good for
us now or Mr big shot comment for the
one thing that matters most if you can't
talk to me your father you got all the
money but you know what you don't have
you don't have no heart you ain't got
two balls you have to let other people's
dream of you die so that your dream can
live because there's only so much of you
to go around everybody else is trying to
get you to be the version of you that
best serves them including your family I
don't think it's a malicious intention
but they have goals for you that are
probably not your goals for you and
somebody's goals have to die and where
most of them die is right in the middle
which is you try and do theirs and you
try and do yours and you actually
accomplish neither so you might as well
do a hundred percent yours do none of
theirs and then actually achieve the
long-term goal which they probably have
is that you live a happy and successful
life you only get there by saying no in
the short term to get the long yes this
is a big one this is business contacts
and this is one of the hardest ones to
say no to so you hop on the call you hop
on the zoom call you take the hey got a
second say you got 15. I'll show you
literally I looked at my inbox let me
tell you the actual words what it sounds
like hey I wanted to touch base real
quick about something hey I've got this
opportunity I think you're going to want
to take a look at let's catch up it's
been a minute it's not the 10 minutes
they're stealing from me it's the time
that I'm thinking about what I'm gonna
say before I get on the call it's what
I'm thinking about after the call it's
the one I wake up the next morning and
I'm still thinking about someone else's
business rather than my own and it's the
actual cost of switching they've done a
ton of research on this but basically
you are like four times more productive
per unit of time if you do one task
rather than try and go A and B and they
just did it between two tasks just
asking people to go switch between task
a and then do task B and they were
different tasks and it took people four
times as long versus just doing a and
then B so when people interrupt your day
think about it as they just 4X how much
longer it's going to take me to get this
thing done that's the real cost of
saying yes to them now in the beginning
if you want to hop on calls to other
people because you want to provide value
to them by all means do it but you're
being conscious about it so if you have
trouble being productive or getting the
things that you want done or achieving
the Big Goal then I would consider
entering a season of no there was a
season when I was going from six
locations to ten now I ultimately talked
to a mentor decided to sell my location
is to turn into licensing and I was like
sucks right now I was like I'm
working 80 hours 100 hours a week every
hour of every day I gave up football I
gave up Netflix and what I started doing
is writing down the things that I was
willing to sacrifice for my goal rather
than things that I was willing to do a
lot of times people have these really
big to-do lists but what I don't think
people do is make really big to-do lists
everybody ahead of you has the same time
so if you're working all day and you're
not making progress as fast as you want
it means the people ahead of you it's
not that they're doing things you aren't
it's that you're doing things they are
they're choosing to say no to more
activities than you are and if you say
no to everything else what's left is the
work in front of you that just he's
doing Jerry Seinfeld talked about how he
wrote comedy he never forced himself to
write but he said during the time block
he wasn't allowed to do anything else
but right he said I could sit there
bored but I couldn't do anything else
except for right it's a long time to
spend on something that means absolutely
nothing but that's what I do that's what
people want me to do is spend a lot of
time wastefully
so that then I can then waste their time
people aren't willing to sit for that
two or three minutes and they allow
themselves to get distracted and so I
think one of the easiest ways to be
really productive is just allow no space
for anything else to occur and then what
happens by default is you become
productive because you have nothing else
to do when I need to change a behavior I
try and change the environment rather
than changing myself because it's way
easier to change everything else than to
change you